Claw X just changed how everyone uses
OpenClaw. Most people have no idea
exists yet. So right now, OpenClaw is
one of the most powerful AI agent
systems on the planet. It can work for
you 24/7, automate your tasks, talk to
apps, schedule jobs, all of it. But
there's one massive problem. You have to
use command line to run it. Um, that's
like having a Ferrari, but the only way
to drive it with a manual written in
Japanese. So, Claw X fixes that. And
this is a brand new free desktop app
that puts OpenClaw inside a clean,
beautiful um UI as you can see right
here. And this runs via a desktop app,
which is pretty cool. Now, this is a
brand new free desktop app that
basically helps you use OpenClaw, but
you don't need to type commands. You
don't need any confusing setup. There's
no technically needed. You just install
it through a setup wizard and then your
AI agent is live. And I actually got
OpenClaw to set up directly. So I'll
show you exactly how I got that to work
and we can run through that in a second.
So if you go back to open claw
which you can see right here what I
literally did and this was really easy
to set up. I just got the GitHub details
of claw X. So it's a free open source
project on GitHub. As you can see I took
the URL of GitHub then plugged it into
openclaw and said install this for
openclaw please. Right. and it kind of
creates X and as you can see this is
running locally but the interesting
thing about this is it's it's inside a
desktop app so it almost feels like
called co-work and that sort of thing um
which is pretty powerful. Now it took a
few minutes to generate but then once it
did it gives me an overview of what it's
doing, how it works, etc. It sets it up
automatically inside the chat as you can
see and then it will tell you okay this
is set up and good to go. Now it also
for example asked me it said installed
now as you can see. Um, but it did ask
me like, "Do you want to set this up as
an app
inside Mac OS?" And I was like, "Yeah,
let's do that." Right. And then from
here, we actually got the full app as
you can see. So, inside the desktop app,
we've got Telegram, Discord, WhatsApp.
It just makes it way easier to manage,
and it's a pretty clean UI as well. So,
you can see we've got Discord connected
here. And it gives you kind of like this
mission control as well. So, you got
like how many connected um you can
easily like set up a new channel as well
if you want to set up a new channel
here. So you can click on Telegram, add
the bot token and the allowed user ID.
So it's really easy to connect other
apps. You could add WhatsApp and that
sort of thing as well. Just scan the QR
code. You can also, for example, go to
the dashboard here. This kind of like
mission control where you can see the
gateway, what skills you set up,
everything else. And then you've got all
the models that you're using over here.
Inside the settings, you can change
between light and dark. You can change
the language, the AI providers that you
have. So, it's quite easy to, for
example, add uh other APIs like you
could even add O Lama and run this for
free locally as well, which is pretty
cool. And then you can add custom AIs
here, but Anthropic, OpenAI, Google,
they're all available. And that means
you can just configure the setup of your
OpenClaw way faster by doing this. And
it's super easy to do. You can also
download the latest updates inside this
section. You've got the dashboard,
channels, skills, schedule, tasks, and
then the main chat, right? So you can
actually just chat with openclaw um
directly inside the chat here. So if you
say hey are you working this will be
connected to my open claw and the cool
thing about all of this is you can
easily get it to you can easily get open
core to set this up yourself right which
means you you don't even need to like
run the terminal commands to set up as
well which is pretty cool right and you
can see here it's it's working directly
it's awesome. So let's see what we got
inside the questions here. Greg says hey
aren't you finding open core so full of
bugs? Absolutely. Yeah it's very buggy.
I mean, that's what you're going to get
with like open source projects, right?
Open source projects, you're always
going to get issues where it's like
where it's, for example, like breaking
or struggling or that sort of thing,
right? And it happens all the time. So,
um, I would just be aware that this can
happen. There's some issues from time to
time, but yeah, you could you you're
going to get that with like open source
projects. It's not like Claude where,
you know, it's a really clean smooth
experience. Even like the updating
section here, it struggles with, but
that's basically how to set up Claw X.
That's how to run it. You can see here
it's running inside the chat. I've shown
you how it works etc. And you can run it
just as an application which is pretty
cool. It's also quite easy to create
scheduled tasks and manage your schedule
tasks as you can see. And the other
thing here is as well like it's kind of
managing all the all the problems that
people have right. So for example people
struggle with the the terminal setup on
openclaw. So with this you just have
like a one-click installation. the
configuration files can be quite
difficult, but with claw X, you get like
the visual um real-time validation and
that sort of thing. And then there's
process management, uh multiple AI
providers, and it's much easier to like
add skills and plugins and that sort of
thing. So, that's basically how to use
it, how to set up, how to get it
working. I've shown you what it looks
like. It's pretty cool. Definitely worth
checking out. Again, it does feel like
almost like the the Claude co-workclaw,
if that makes sense. And you can get
OpenClaw to just set up inside the chat.
Just paste in the GitHub details. So,
thanks so much for watching. If you
haven't already, check out the AR Profit
Boarding. We've got tons of video notes,
as you can see right here. We've also
got a full framework on how to use this,
a 30-day plan on how to set up a bunch
of use cases here as well, and also 100
prompts on how you can test this out
with Claw X and just decide like, you
know, do you prefer the desktop app or
the gateway or that sort of thing. So,
that's basically how it works. Now,
inside the AR profit boardroom as well,
we have a full six-hour course on how to
master Open Claw with step-by-step
guides and that sort of thing. We have
another three-hour course here and we
update this every single day with new
updates. So, for example, Quen 3.5
released a new model you can run with
OpenClaw this morning. We've already
done a video tutorial on full
step-by-step guide here. And we actually
date the updates. You can see for
example, 2nd of March, 1 of March, etc.
And we're adding new updates every
single day. So, this is all inside the
AR profit boarding link in the comments
description or go to the AI
profitboarding.com. Inside the
community, you can post questions, get
help, get support. There's always people
online cuz there's 2,500 people inside
here. I also do weekly updates. Now,
inside the weekly AI updates, what I do
is I look at my 60 hours of research
each week with AI, and I break down
what's useful and what's not, just to
save you time and to help you avoid
information overload. We also have a
daily accountability group. And again,
this just helps you avoid information
overload so you can stay focused and and
just really focus on what matters to you
most. Right now, inside the classroom,
you can get all of our best trainings.
So, for example, if you want to go from
beginner to expert with AI automation,
you can do that here. Plus, learn how to
build your first AI agent in under five
minutes. Additionally, you can get our
playbook which shows you how to automate
X, newsletters, shorts, avatar videos,
and everything else. Inside the SAP
updates, you can get daily updates like
you can see right here, um, with all the
new guides and that sort of thing. And
then you can also go inside the map and
meet people in your local area.
Additionally, you can learn how to get
more clients with the agency course. You
can watch back the coaching calls. You
can learn how to rank number one with AI
SEO and also how to grow a YouTube
channel with AI based on what's working
for me. So that's all inside the AI
profit boardroom link in the comments
description or go to the AI profit
boardroom.com. Shackle says, "Are there
tears to claw a better or worse?" Yeah,
there's there's plenty of alternatives
that I've tested that have just not been
as good. We've got loads of guides
inside here. Does copore support open
router? I think it does as far as I'm
aware. I think so. Are there tiers to
claw? We already answered that one. Claw
X update open claw automatically. Well,
you just set up auto updates inside the
gateway of or if you want to
automatically update where it says I
want to build an autonomous job
application setup. Yeah. So, you can I
I've done that with the way that I did
that before. I built a job board with um
data button. Data button was the uh one
that I used and we have a full tutorial
on how I did that right here. Right. So,
we have a full tutorial on how data
button work right there. So, that's
basically how it works. Thanks very much
for watching. Appreciate as always. I've
answered all the questions. Thanks for
being on today. I'll see you on the next
one. Cheers. is Bubba.